Krass, nicht wahr? Oh.
Aber ich muss hier runter.
Es ist 6 Uhr.
Es ist schon etwas steil.
David!
- Ja?
Sollen wir die Steigeisen anziehen?
- Nein, für die paar ...
Es sind nur 20 m, dann ist gut.
Wieder ein Steilstück
voller vereister Spuren.
Ein Sturz kann hier
fatale Folgen haben.
Geht's?
- Nein, nicht so gut.
Wie?
- Nicht so gut.
Ein Seil soll's richten.
Der vereiste Steilhang
ist zu gefährlich,
um ihn ohne Sicherung zu befahren.
Ist nicht so schlimm, oder?
Wenn man von Anfang an anseilt,
ist es dann - phu - gut.
Der 72-jährige Paul Zeller
macht den Anfang.
Ich hab's langsam gesehen.
Wenn ich unten ankomme,
könnt ihr applaudieren.
Okay.
- Gerne.
Carmen Giezendanner,
die kaufmännische Angestellte, folgt.
Nein, mit diesen Schuhen
habe ich das Gefühl,
Es ist uneben. Wenn's schon ein Seil
hat, nehme ich es in die Hand.
Wenn's sein müsste.
Dann würde ich es überleben.
- Es geht, macht aber keinen Spass.
Ja, genau.
Die ehemalige Weltcupfahrerin
Fränzi Aufdenblatten befürchtet,
dass sich die Bindung
durch einen Schlag öffnen könnte.
Sie wählt das sichere Seil.
Einzig Olympiasiegerin
Dominique Gisin wagt die Abfahrt.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Ja, ja.
Es ist schon verdammt hart.
- Ja, ja.
So richtig hart.
Du bist es gewohnt,
auf so hartem Zeug zu fahren.
Aber nicht
mit solchen Hindernissen dazwischen.
Ich sagte, der Pistenfahrer
habe heute Nacht versagt.
Es war etwas unheimlich,
es ist steil.
Es ist der Moment,
wenn dem man lernt, mutig zu sein.
Aber jetzt ist es schön.
Jetzt wird es etwas weicher.
Bis wir dem anderen Hang
runterfahren können, ist es sulzig.
Dann wird es schön.
Es hat sich gelohnt.
Seit drei Tagen ist die zusammen-
gewürfelte Gruppe unterwegs
auf der Haute Route
von Chamonix nach Zermatt.
Ein Pensionär, ein Heilpädagoge,
eine kaufmännische Angestellte,
ehemalige Skirennfahrerinnen,
ein CEO und eine Haushaltslehrerin
wagen gemeinsam
das Abenteuer in den Alpen.
Die dritte Etappe
führt sie von der Cabane du Trient
auf den Col de la Grande Lui.
Eine lange Abfahrt
bis ins Tal nach La Fouly.
Dann mit Bus nach Verbier
und mit der Bahn
wieder hoch zur Cabane Mont Fort.
600 m Aufstieg und 1'700 m Abfahrt
sind heute zu bewältigen.
Dass die vereisten Spuren tückisch
und die Skibindungen nicht
so stabil sind wie bei Pistenskis,
bekommt Dominique Gisin
etwas später zu spüren.
(Dominique)
Jetzt habe ich beide Skis verloren.
Einen hier, einen dort.
Skitourenleiterin Yolanda hilft.
Die Skis müssen so schräg sein?
Ja, aber sie dreht aus.
Ist das die,
die vorne auslösen sollte?
Ja.
Oh, dein Stock.
- Das habe ich gesehen.
Was hast du gemacht?
- Ich bin über den Absatz runter.
Ich hatte es nicht gesehen.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Manchmal ist es an der Zeit,
aus dem Alltag auszubrechen.
Sich für das Zeit zu nehmen,
wovon man geträumt hat,
und dem Leben
ein neues Kapitel hinzuzufügen.
* Sphärischer Jodel *
80 km, 7'000 Höhenmeter
auf über 3'000 m ü.M.
In sechs Tagen,
das ist die Haute Route.
Die berühmteste Skitour der Alpen
und für jeden Einzelnen der Gruppe
ein Traum, der sich nun erfüllt.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Die Route ist gespickt mit
langen Aufstiegen mit Fell und Skis.
Und steilen Couloirs, die nur
mit Steigeisen zu bewältigen sind.
(David) Okay, tipptopp!
Die Felle wegnehmen! Ähm ...
Steigeisen anziehen,
Skis auf den Rucksack binden!
Die Stöcke ebenfalls
auf den Rucksack und Pickel nehmen!
Und macht eine Pause.
Okay?
- Ja.
Yolanda.
Yolanda, Severin und Fränzi
machen eine Seilschaft,
und der Rest kommt mit mir.
Die Wenigsten
haben grosse Tourenerfahrung.
Bis auf Yolanda,
die heute eine Seilschaft übernimmt.
Ja. Ja, coole Sache.
Schön da hoch.
Tolle Leute am Seil.
Es läuft was.
Die Laune? Ja, die ist besser -
als noch vor 30 Min.
Ich habe es ohne Fluchen geschafft.
Aber ich merke es schon.
Gut, ich bin auch eine Susi,
ich jammere gerne, muss ich sagen.
Da bin ich ehrlich.
* Lachen *
Fränzi lacht.
Fränzi kann immer dumm schwatzen,
das ist ihr Vorteil.
Sie bringt sogar noch was raus,
wenn sie am Limit ist.
Mein Jammern ist jetzt das Grinsen.
* Windrauschen *
Vor ihnen
liegt das 200 m steile Couloir
über den Col de la Grande Lui,
die heutige Schlüsselstelle.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Sie sind als Gruppe alleine
in der riesigen Gletscherlandschaft
unterwegs.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Gut, es geht.
(David) Das ist der ...
Vorsicht, hier warten!
Der Bergschrund.
Der Hang ist steil,
furchteinflössend für jene,
die es nicht gewohnt sind,
mit Steigeisen zu gehen.
(David) Gut, du kannst kommen!
Nicht am Seil festhalten!
Heute ist David
als Bergführer besonders gefragt.
Peter, nicht am Seil festhalten!
Er hat die weniger erfahrenen
Berggänger am Seil -
wie Peter, den Heilpädagogen,
der mutig werden will, oder Carmen,
die im Andenken an ihre verstorbene
Mutter auf der Tour dabei ist.
(Carmen) Moment!
Ist gut bei euch?
Nach dem Ausfall
des Bergführers Bruno Jelk
ist SAC-Tourenleiterin Yolanda
heute eingesprungen
und führt die zweite Seilschaft
mit Fränzi und Severin.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Langsam arbeitet sich die Gruppe
im Wind hoch.
Das Seil
soll einen Absturz verhindern.
(David) Können wir weiter?
Warte,
bis der Reissverschluss zu ist!
Yolanda, hier kannst du gut sichern.
- Okay.
Vorsicht, Stein!
(David) Gut, ja.
Immer schön weitergehen!
Stein!
Super, Peter, komm!
Es ist nicht mehr weit.
Vorsicht, das Seil unten,
du stehst drauf.
(Peter) Gut.
Das geht gut.
Ist der brüchige Fels kein Problem?
- Wie?
Mit dem brüchigen Fels.
- Nein.
Warte bitte, bis ich es sage!
Gut, du kannst kommen.
Pass auf,
dass du nicht aufs Seil ...
Sie macht das sehr ruhig.
Das gibt mir auch Ruhe.
Du kannst gehen,
sobald das Seil gestreckt ist.
Ich finde es schon cool, wenn es
in einem Schwierigkeitsgrad ist,
in dem ich mich wohlfühle.
Und wenn die Kapazität da ist,
ich für die anderen schauen kann.
Fräzi, ich komme auch.
Wie bitte?
- Ich komme auch.
Ruhig und gelassen
hat Yolanda ihre Seilschaft
durch die steile Flanke geführt.
Wie lange brauchten wir?
- 20 oder 30 Min.
Steigeisen weg.
Was nun folgt,
ist eine lange Abfahrt.
Die Motivation ist gleich
um einen Drittel gestiegen.
Jetzt können wir
endlich mal runterfahren.
Am Morgen haben wir beide beweisen,
dass wir Bruchpiloten sind,
aber wir wissen jetzt, dass man
die Bindungen noch anziehen kann.
Es zieht mich richtig.
Der Schnee wird auch super.
Nur noch ... Ich glaube,
es geht verdammt lange runter.
Es ist sicher etwas anderes
als das, was ich bisher
in meinem Leben gemacht habe.
Wir sind alles andere
als Ausdauersportler.
Das ist natürlich
eine ganz andere Belastung.
Es sind schon Sachen, die
alles andere als alltäglich sind.
Und v.a. noch in dieser Menge.
Ich meine, heute ging es sehr gut,
gestern auch.
Aber man weiss:
Jetzt folgen noch drei Tage,
an denen es
eher mehr ist als weniger.
Die Gesamtmenge an Belastung
ist sicher eine Herausforderung.
Denkst du daran?
Manchmal, in einem schwachen Moment.
Nein. Logisch, man weiss,
dass die Tage noch kommen.
Man teilt es sich also etwas ein.
Aber ich denke,
es sollte schon machbar sein.
Dann endlich, das,
worauf sich die Skirennfahrerinnen
am meisten gefreut haben:
eine Abfahrt.
Bergführer David Fasel
fährt mit Dominique,
Fränzi und Severin vorne weg.
* Sphärischer Jodel *
Der Weg auf dem Gletscher
muss gut gewählt werden.
* Sphärischer Jodel *
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Ja, die Originalroute, die wir
hatten, wäre auf der Rückseite ...
Bergführer Ralph Weber,
der auch für die Sicherheit
des Fernsehteams zuständig ist,
folgt mit Yolanda
und der zweiten Gruppe.
Wir gehen jetzt linksrum.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Die schneebedeckte Fläche
des Gletschers ist tückisch.
Immer wieder tauchen unvermittelt
riesige offene Spalten auf,
die für die Gruppe
schwer ersichtlich sind.
Huch, ja!
Mega.
- So sieht's schön aus.
Jetzt kannst du hier hinten schauen.
Bei solchen Sachen
geht man jeweils zu Fuss.
Ja, ja.
(Dominique) Ja, hier
ist es schwieriger geworden.
(Fränzi) Zeitweise
hebt es einen fast aus den Schuhen.
Mich hob es mal so, dass mir
der Rucksack an den Kopf knallte.
Gut, trage ich einen Helm.
* Dominique lacht. *
(Dominique) Der Saharastaub.
- (Fränzi) Ja, nicht wahr?
Rund 1 Std.
hat die Abfahrt von über 3'000 m
bis ins Tal nach La Fouly
auf fast 1'600 m gedauert.
Auch der 72-jährige Paul,
der die Haute Route
schon vor 50 Jahren gemacht hat,
hat's geschafft.
Tochter Yolanda hilft.
(David)
Ging es, Paul? Oben war's gut, oder?
Super.
Einmal machte es bei dir so.
- Ja, unten.
(Fränzi) Dabei war mir kalt.
Vor 1 Std. noch waren sie
im Sturm in Fels und Eis geklettert.
Grösser
könnte der Gegensatz nicht sein.
(David) Gratuliere.
- (Dominique) Viva.
(David) Du hast mich
im Skifahren fertiggemacht.
Yolanda, vielen Dank.
- Merci, Yolanda, gut geführt.
Wir sind jetzt so in der Hälfte.
In der Hälfte der Haute Route.
- Ja.
Noch nicht ganz, aber ...
(Fränzi) Ist morgen
der schlimmste Tag? - Nein.
Übermorgen?
- Nein.
Es gibt keinen.
Aber was denkt ihr bisher?
Gefällt es euch?
Oder würdet ihr am liebsten heute
abbrechen und nach Hause gehen?
Zieht ihr es durch bis nach Zermatt?
- Klar ziehen wir es durch.
Wirklich?
- Ja.
Ist es ein Müssen
oder macht es euch Spass?
Es macht viel Spass.
Wir haben goldige Bedingungen.
Habt ihr es euch so vorgestellt?
Oder habt ihr es euch anders,
weniger streng vorgestellt?
Oder strenger?
Ich dachte, die Passagen
mit Abseilen und so seien weniger.
Hast du das gar nicht erwartet?
Ähm ...
- Nicht so extrem steil.
Nicht so extrem steil, nein.
- Mir geht es gleich.
Es ging dann gut, es war okay.
Oder z.B.
mit den Steigeisen hoch ...
Wie heute Morgen?
- Mit den Skis auf dem Rücken.
Das stellte ich mir schon vor,
aber es war doch relativ steil.
Also, hättest du einmal einen
Ausschritt nach hinten gemacht,
wärst du ...
hättest du uns gehalten.
* Lachen *
Genau.
- Normalerweise.
Normalerweise.
(Fränzi)
Es gibt etwas Abwechslung, oder?
Wenn man nur mit den Fellen
gehen, gehen, gehen würde,
wäre es nicht ...
Paul, hast du es dir so vorgestellt?
Du hast es
schon vor 50 Jahren gemacht.
Ich kannte das schon.
Ich kannte es vom Bergsteigen.
- Ja, ja.
Einzig die Abfahrt gestern,
die war etwas hart.
Ich erinnere mich nicht mehr daran.
- Frühmorgens.
Ach so.
Aber heute ging's gut?
- Heute ging's gut.
Als wir das Seil ...
Am Anfang hast du schon etwas ...
Ja, als es runterging.
- Aber mit dem Seil war's gut.
Ja, mit dem Seil schon.
Ja, aber du bist in der Hüfte
halt nicht mehr 35 Jahre alt.
Gut, das ist halt einfach so.
Dann gehen wir weiter, oder?
- Bist du denn zufrieden mit uns?
Ja, ich gehe gerne
mit euch nach Zermatt.
Heute Abend gehen wir
in der Mont-Fort gut essen,
schlafen gut und dann ...
... begeben wir uns in die Bergwelt.
Jetzt geniessen wir
noch die Zivilisation.
Also ich bin fast lieber in den
Bergen, aber dann geht's weiter.
Jus de pommes?
- Morgen ... Also, das ist gut.
Rivella?
- Schön, dass ihr mitkommt.
Gerne.
Ja, gib ihnen einen Kuss von mir!
Ja. Ja, ist gut.
Ja, der ist sowieso ... ja.
Gut, also ...
Tschüss, danke. Tschau.
Ja, ist gut. Tschau.
Sie sind am Spielen,
haben keine Zeit für die Mama.
Das ist ein gutes Zeichen.
Yolanda ist seit drei Jahren
alleinerziehende Mutter zweier Buben
und war in all der Zeit
noch nie länger von ihnen getrennt.
Weiter geht die Tour
per Bus nach Verbier,
dann mit der Bahn
ins Skigebiet von Mont-Fort
zur Mont-Fort-Hütte auf 2'457 m.
Die Hütte steht mitten im Skigebiet
und ist
mit allem Konfort ausgestattet.
* Gemächliche Akkordeonklänge
im Viervierteltakt *
Zeit, aufzutanken und Kräfte
zu sammeln für die nächsten Tage.
Es sind Viererzimmer.
Einmal vier, einmal drei.
Macht untereinander aus,
wer mit wem ins Zimmer darf!
Ich schnappe mir einfach mal eines.
* Lachen *
Hallo? Familie?
Ah, hier sind wir.
Wir sind schon zu viert,
weil ihr Vater noch kommt.
Ah.
- Also nicht, dass ...
Dann ... Wo ist noch eines? Links?
Hallo?
Du stehst mir im Weg.
- Aber nur ein wenig, oder?
Ja. Gut.
Ich glaube, du bist hier.
Sie haben keinen Platz für mich,
weil Yolandas Papi dort ist.
Ihr müsst leider
mit mir Vorlieb nehmen.
Was heisst hier leider?
- Ich quassel wieder.
Du darfst natürlich zu den Ladys.
- Aha.
Nach drei Tagen eine erste Dusche.
Huch!
* Stimmengewirr *
Wollt ihr schon was trinken?
Soll ich eine Flasche Weisswein ...
- Das wäre ... Nicht Weisswein.
Ich muss zuerst Wasser haben.
- Kriegst du.
Beides.
- Beides. Und Weisswein.
Auch Internetempfang
gehört zum Service der Hütte.
Ich habe von den Bergführern
einen Sonderauftrag erhalten:
Ich muss schauen, ob ich hier oben
auf dem iPad Empfang habe.
Ob ich Schweizer Fernsehen empfange.
Um Champions League zu schauen.
Bayern gegen Real
ist heute angesagt.
Zum Wohl. Es war
ein megaschöner Tag. Zum Wohl.
Danke. Viva.
- Zum Wohl.
Eine schöne Idee.
Zeit, zu entspannen.
Oder wie in Dominique Gisins
und Fränzi Aufdenblattens Fall:
auf ihre Beziehung als Weltcup-
fahrerinnen und Konkurrentinnen
zurückzublicken.
Es kommt drauf an.
Wir standen uns nie extrem nahe.
Genau. Und jetzt vielleicht ...
Es ist wie im normalen Leben.
Ich glaube, mit einigen
entsteht eine echte Freundschaft
und mit anderen kommt man gut aus,
aber es ist nicht so, dass wir
gemeinsam Ferien gemacht hätten.
Nein.
- Es ist wie im Job.
Einigen steht man näher,
anderen weniger.
Ja, es ist auch ein Job.
- Es ist ja eigentlich unser Job.
Aber generell ist es speziell,
dass man dann wenig Kontakt hat
zu den Leuten,
mit denen man gefahren ist.
Denn davor spielte sich das Leben
irgendwie am selben Ort ab,
doch jetzt ist man verstreut.
Habt ihr jetzt andere Seiten
aneinander kennengelernt?
Ihr kanntet euch ja schon gut.
Ja, das ...
- Es ist schwierig, noch etwas ...
Oder könnt ihr etwas relativieren?
Es ist einfach gechillter.
Aber ich weiss nicht, ob es ist,
weil wir jetzt älter sind.
Ja.
Prinzipiell
ist der Konkurrenzdruck mal weg.
Genau.
- Der ist weg.
Bei uns beiden
schätzte ich es extrem,
dass wir uns
gar den Servicemann teilten.
Obwohl wir Konkurrentinnen waren,
obwohl wir nicht best friends waren.
Aber wir waren professionell genug
und wussten,
dass wir beide davon profitieren,
wenn wir das gemeinsam tun.
Dann machten wir das.
Auch wenn ...
Als sie Olympiasiegerin wurde,
konnte ich ja nicht mal
das Rennen fahren.
Es war einer der tougheren Momente.
Aber ich musste sagen:
"Die Leistung war einfach geil."
Sie konnte an diesem Tag
ihre Stärke voll ausspielen.
Dann musst du einfach sagen,
dass du den Hut ziehst.
Es hilft dir dann selbst auch,
damit umzugehen,
wenn du es dem anderen gönnst.
Es ist etwas, was ich gelernt habe:
Du tust dir keinen Gefallen,
wenn du anderen etwas nicht gönnst.
Wenn Fränzi das jetzt sagt, bedeutet
mir das natürlich sehr viel.
Denn sie weiss ganz genau,
welche Leistung das war.
Das ist eine grosse Lebensschule,
dass man damit umzugehen lernt.
* Gemächliche Akkordeonklänge *
Die Gruppe wächst durch
die Herausforderungen der Haute Route
immer mehr zu einem Team zusammen.
In den Bergen lernen sie einander mit
persönlichen Hochs und Tiefs kennen.
Nur einer fehlt:
Bergführer Bruno Jelk,
der die Gruppe vor einem Tag
aus gesundheitlichen Gründen
verlassen musste
und für den Yolanda
heute eingesprungen ist.
Ich habe mit Bruno telefoniert:
Ihm geht's nicht gut.
Der verbrachte den Tag auf dem Klo.
Wir dachten,
wir könnten ihn noch einfliegen.
Heute ging es ja tipptopp.
Wir haben aber dennoch entschieden -
weil wir
eine relativ grosse Gruppe sind
und unterschiedliche Niveaus
haben ...
Damit wir die Gruppe mal teilen und
auch mal einen Gipfel machen können,
brauchen wir doch noch jemanden,
der mir ein wenig hilft.
Es liegt auf der Hand: Ralph.
* Lachen, Applaus *
Du hast es tipptopp gemacht.
Aber wir haben
so angefangen und gesehen,
dass wir schon
eine relativ grosse Gruppe sind.
Normalerweise geht man mit
fünf Leuten auf so eine Haute Route.
Jetzt haben wir entschieden,
dass Ralph mit uns geht.
So haben wir auch
mehr Möglichkeiten.
Er hat heute auch schon geholfen,
das Fixseil eingehängt.
So ist mir auch wohler -
und allen anderen wohl auch.
So haben wir mehr Sicherheit drin.
Ist das okay?
Tipptopp.
- Vielen Dank, Ralph.
Morgen folgt die längste Tour.
Aber wir haben ja gerade
ein Fondue gegessen.
Um 4 Uhr aufstehen, um 5 Uhr los.
Die Tour beginnt
auf der Cabane Mont-Fort.
Ein erster Aufstieg
auf den Col de la Chaux.
Es folgt die Rosablanche
auf über 3'000 m.
Und danach
eine lange Laufpassage am Lac des Dix
bis zur Cabane des Dix.
Mit 9 Std., 17 km
und 1'800 m Aufstieg
ist es die längste Etappe
der Haute Route.
Hier ist der mühsame Teil mit
den Fellen. Hier müssen wir beissen.
Es wird warm sein.
Dann geht es so flach nach hinten -
lange, lange, lange, lange ...
Wie viele Kilometer?
- Dem See entlang.
Ja, dem See entlang bis zur Hütte.
Als Zückerchen gibt's
noch eine Runde Champions League.
(Originalton) Erste blaue Flecken,
die sich die Spieler geholt haben.
Es geht hier ordentlich zur Sache.
* Sphärischer Jodel *
Tagwacht ist um 4 Uhr.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
* Sphärischer Jodel *
Die erste Etappe startet auf
der vereisten Piste des Skigebietes.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Licht aus! Ich schlafe noch.
Die Wettervorhersage für heute
ist gut.
Doch in den nächsten Tagen kündigt
sich eine Schlechtwetterfront an.
Im Tal sammelt sich
die Feuchtigkeit in den Wolken.
Erste Blessuren
machen sich bemerkbar.
Ja, Blasen.
Aber wir reden nicht darüber.
Ja, wir sind jetzt wohl
nicht mal 1 Std. gelaufen, 45 Min.
Schon über Blasen zu reden,
wenn es 9 Std. dauert?
Das nimmt ein böses Ende.
Bis jetzt geht's,
ich hab noch ein wenig geschlafen.
Gehend.
Aber heute dauert es lange.
Frag mich in 3 Std. nochmals.
Jetzt in der Traverse würde ich
links die Steighilfe reintun.
Es ist wie so ...
Der linke ist weiter unten,
so ist es angenehmer, zu laufen.
Ja, gut. Hier schon reintun?
- Ja, ich würde schon.
David gibt Peter wertvolle Tipps,
wie er heute Kräfte sparen kann.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Es ist der vierte Tag
auf der Haute Route.
Über 24 Std.
mit Tourenski und Steigeisen
hat die Gruppe bereits in den Beinen.
* Majestätische Klänge *
Jeder kämpft für sich und versucht,
seinen eigenen Rhythmus zu finden.
Denn noch liegt die Hälfte
der Haute Route vor ihnen.
Was geschieht hier vorn?
Spitzkehrenübung, hiess es.
Ich weiss noch nicht,
ob ich da mitmache.
Mal schauen.
Ich bin froh, wenn ich hochkomme.
Ich sagte von Anfang an,
ich würde es nicht machen.
* Sie lacht. *
Der 72-jährige Paul hat seine Skis
dem Bergführer abgegeben.
Umso willkommener die Pause für alle
auf dem Col de la Chaux.
Hey.
- So, den Ersten haben wir.
Den ersten Teil schon.
CEO Severin,
der ehemalige Zehnkämpfer, entspannt.
Wie auch Fränzi,
die Ex-Spitzensportlerin.
Es ist wohl auch nicht konform,
wie ich das mache.
Ich bin froh um die
Überbleibsel meiner Skifahrer-Beine.
Die helfen hier noch flott mit.
Zack!
Gestern Morgen kam ich
so richtig in einen Flow.
Und es lief irgendwie automatisch.
Doch heute Morgen war es ein Krampf.
Warum? Du bist doch
ein reflektierter Mensch.
Bestimmt hast du eine Antwort.
Ich glaube, weil wir nicht
schön hintereinander gegangen sind,
sondern nebeneinander.
Niemand wusste, wer vorne ist.
Aber das ist nur eine Vermutung.
Und schon die Frage:
Ich spüre jetzt meine Beine,
ich bin schon
am Anschlagsmoment der Kräfte.
Wie wird dieser Tag wohl?
Das hängt sicher zusammen.
Aber wir haben jetzt die Erste.
- Da bin ich froh.
Aber wenn ich hier runterschaue,
wird mir etwas mulmig.
Nicht nur ein wenig.
Findest du, wir sind zu schnell
oder schneller gegangen?
Das kann ich nicht einschätzen,
aber ich kam in keinen Flow.
Ich hab mit mir gekämpft.
Hast du das gar nicht so realisiert?
Nein, ich habe das ganz ...
Es war noch gut,
wir konnten die Piste hochgehen.
Ja.
Es ging erst richtig los,
als wir oben an der Piste waren.
Am Morgen war es
eine Weile etwas schnell.
Aber dafür sind wir jetzt oben.
Ja, aber es wird ein langer Tag.
- Man sagt's, ja.
Es gibt noch einige Aufstiege.
V.a. dem See entlang nach hinten
wird es dann etwas mühsam.
Der Rucksack mit allem Material
wiegt rund 10 kg.
Gehen wir? Es wird frisch.
Ist gut? Dürfen wir gehen?
Ich frage nicht, wir gehen.
Das Gepäck trägt jeder selber -
von Hütte zu Hütte.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Im Nebel wird auch die Orientierung
immer schwieriger.
Bergführer David ist gefordert.
Siehst du gut mit der Sonnenbrille?
- Ja.
Zieh sie mal aus!
Siehst du nicht besser?
Ich hab Angst wegen der Augen.
Schau doch einfach,
ob du ohne besser siehst.
Nicht?
- Ja ...
So halb? Einmal unten, einmal oben.
- Ja, genau.
Hier wird es gleich etwas flach.
Haltet etwas Abstand, dann könnt ihr
die Skis ziehen lassen.
Wir gehen etwas langsamer.
Komm mir hinterher!
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Es geht noch weit.
- Ja, ja.
Lieber gehen,
wenn es noch nicht so warm ist.
Laufen, wenn es nicht so warm ist,
und reden, wenn es warm ist.
Vor rund 3 Std. ist die Gruppe
in der Hütte gestartet.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
David drückt aufs Tempo.
Am Nachmittag wird es wieder heiss.
Hinter der Bergkette
ist der Lac des Dix,
der direkt in der Lawinenzone liegt,
wo nach dem schneereichen Winter
Nasslawinen drohen.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Jacken ausziehen!
(Dominique) Geht's hier weiter?
Oder weiter aufwärts?
Äh, ja ... äh ...
Aber jetzt ist es zunächst flach.
Der Spitz hier vorn
ist die Rosablanche.
Um im Zeitplan zu bleiben,
will David den Gipfel der Rosablanche
in 2 Std. erreicht haben.
Ich schicke ein paar Fotos.
Igitt, alles nass!
Das ist schon etwas eklig.
Warum hast du
die Mütze nicht ausgezogen?
Ich wäre genauso nass geworden.
Man muss immer noch
etwas Potenzial haben.
Es braucht die Möglichkeit,
noch etwas zu verbessern.
Wie beim Fahrrad:
nie den leichtesten Gang rein.
Einen braucht man noch als Reserve.
Es geht etwas besser
und ich habe wohl auch rausgefunden,
woran es liegt.
Es ist mehr der Kopf,
es sind nicht die Beine.
Beim Hochgehen
taucht plötzlich die Frage auf:
"Was mache ich eigentlich?"
Die Frage nach dem Sinn.
Dann sind da viele
durchtrainierte Leute, Sportler,
die nebenher einfach reden können.
Ich denke: "Ich möchte
mitreden können, kann aber nicht."
Dazu fehlt mir die Puste.
Dann dreht es im Kopf: "Wer bin ich?
Was mache ich überhaupt hier?"
"Gehöre ich in diese Gruppe
oder nicht?"
"Warum schaffe ich es nicht,
mitzureden?"
Dann beginnt es zu rotieren,
das kennen wohl viele andere auch.
Dann muss ich das bewusst
wieder ausschalten und sagen:
"Es ist ein Paradies.
Schaut euch um! Es ist so schön."
Dann geht es wieder. Doch dann
kommen diese Stimmen wieder.
Dann wird man sie wieder los.
So in diesem Modus bin ich jetzt.
* Sphärischer Jodel *
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge
mit sphärischem Jodel *
Laufen. Nur laufen.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge
mit sphärischem Jodel *
Alleine mit sich,
der Natur und seinen Gedanken.
Stundenlang im gleichen Trott.
Keine Ablenkung. Nichts.
So Bewegungen, damit der Ellbogen
z.B. etwas mehr Luft bekommt -
so leichte Genusssachen.
Wie Abwechseln.
Der Takt.
Dass ich dem vor mir nicht auflaufe
und schaue, dass ich schön schiebe.
So immer ein wenig im Kreis.
Das geht gut.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
am dritten, vierten Tag
geht es immer besser mit der Höhe.
Man ist akklimatisiert
und hat das Gefühl fürs Material.
Es geht besser als am Anfang.
Ich sage, ich gehe mit grossen
Schritten meinem Zuhause entgegen.
Ob nun in der Traverse oder anders.
Aber es rückt schon näher.
Das ist cool. Ich freue mich.
Was sagst du deinen Freunden,
wenn sie dich fragen?
Wären Skitouren noch was für dich?
Zumindest sicher nicht
wegen der Abfahrten.
Das war eine diplomatische Antwort.
Nein, sonst ist es wunderschön.
Aber die Abfahrt gestern
war auch eine Entschädigung.
Sie kommen der Rosablanche
und ihrem Ziel Zermatt immer näher.
Felle weg! Skis auf den Rücken!
Die Stöcke ebenfalls.
Und Pickel hervorholen!
Jetzt sind wir
aber nähergekommen, David.
Ja, ja.
- Es kommt immer näher.
Jetzt kommt es näher.
Jetzt gefällt es mir
besser als gestern.
Von hier aus sieht man gut
die Dent Blanche, wie sie raucht.
Ja, genau.
Und da ist das Matterhorn.
Nicht Dent Blanche, Dent d'Herens.
(Fränzi)
Das sieht aus wie ein Vulkan.
Ja, nicht wahr?
Carmen, hast du gesehen? Das ist
der einzige Vulkan in der Schweiz.
Der, der dort raucht.
- Ist kein AKW dahinter?
Nein, nein.
Könnte die Dent Blanche
nicht rechts sein?
Nein, Dent d'Herens.
Aber hier können wir sicher
ein paar schöne Schwünge machen.
Bis wir in den Nebel fahren,
aber vielleicht ist er bis dann weg.
Zum Glück ist Dominique hier. Dann
lasse ich sie gewöhnlich fahren.
Was ist gewöhnlich?
Wenn David wieder auf einer Kante
steht und sagt: "Fahrt mal!
Schön, bist du hier,
dann lasse ich dich fahren.
Ich bin gern das Versuchskaninchen.
Wenn ich nach oben schaue ...
... brauche ich das Gelernte.
Aber ich schaffe das, das ist gut.
Gute Leute, guter Bergführer,
gute Motivatoren.
Es wird klappen.
Noch liegen aber
über zwei Tage vor ihnen,
bevor sie das Matterhorn erreichen.
Der Weg dahin führt
über die Besteigung der Rosablanche.
David klettert mit
der stärkeren Gruppe am Seil voran.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge
mit sphärischem Jodel *
Ralph folgt mit der zweiten Gruppe -
Paul, Peter und Carmen.
Yolanda sichert zuhinterst.
(Fränzi) Mein Pickel
ist einfach zu kurz.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
(Ralph) Wenn man links hochschaut,
sieht man, wo wir runterfahren.
Der Hang nebenan.
- Ich schaue nicht hin.
(Yolanda) Ralph, du hast zwei
mit leichter Höhenangst am Seil.
Was? - Du hast zwei
mit Höhenangst am Seil.
Deshalb wollte ich es geniessen.
- Die sind desinteressiert.
Wir kommen in den Nebel.
- (Ralph) Ja.
Sollen wir weitergehen?
- Langsam, ja.
Okay, ich gehe etwas langsamer.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
(Yolanda) Ja, gestreckt lassen!
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge
mit sphärischem Jodel *
Wir sind fast oben.
Und dann, nach über 5 Std.,
erreicht David mit seinem Team
den höchsten Punkt des Tages,
die Rosablanche.
Bravo. Gut gemacht.
Tipptopp gelaufen.
- Cool.
Fränzi, bravo.
- Merci.
Du warst super.
- Danke dir. Super.
Schau dir die Aussicht an!
- Ja, krass.
Mir gefällt v.a.,
dass wir schon etwas näher sind.
Ja, genau.
(Ralph) Super.
Und auch Ralph folgt
mit Paul, Peter und Carmen am Seil.
(David) Super. Super, Paul.
- (Fränzi) Schön gemacht.
Dem Bergführer gratuliere ich auch.
(Ralph) Wie geht's Paul?
- Jetzt geht's wieder gut.
Es ist gut gegangen. Etwas gelitten.
Ein hervorragender Krieger.
- So komme ich mir vor.
Du hast es gut gemacht.
Danke, du warst
eine tolle Unterstützung.
Gut gemacht. Bravo.
- Vielen Dank.
Gut gelaufen.
- Papi.
Super.
Bist du stolz auf Papa?
- Ja, sicher.
Er zeigt eine super Leistung.
Genial.
Tut so, als sei es schön!
Freude, Euphorie,
aber auch das Wissen,
dass der heutige Tag
noch lange nicht zu Ende ist
und der härteste Teil
noch bevorsteht.
Das sehen Sie in der nächsten Folge:
Komm!
Carmens Blasen werden zum Problem.
Denn es ist noch weit.
Etwas eincremen!
Jetzt haben wir's.
Schwitzen und kämpfen in der Hitze
bis zur Cabane des Dix.
Paul mit seinen 72 Jahren
wird zum Helden.
Mein Papi.
Der macht das sackstark.
Ich habe gerade etwas Augenpipi.
Physikstudentin Dominique Gisin
hat eine neue Formel entdeckt.
Es gibt definitiv eine Formel,
wonach meine Leistungsfähigkeit
mit der Aussentemperatur korreliert.
Stürmischer Aufstieg
auf die Pigne d'Arolla,
bevor die Schlechtwetterfront
hereinbricht,
in der zwei Tage später
sieben Menschen ums Leben kommen.
Und ein letztes Zusammenrücken
im Bivouac des Bouquetins.
Dies und mehr
in der letzten Folge von "Abenteuer
Alpen, die Skitour des Lebens".